hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to wrestling with emotion
now this game has something to do with
wrestlers and possibly dating I'm not
100% sure
oh hello hi friend I wish I knew what
that one Wow
that's the coolest cheeto would that say
oh okay hi
I have no idea what this game is about
but it's promising to be a little bit
weird oh [ __ ] sad bored lonely well then
try wrestling with emotion speed dating
in cuddle town oh that's so nice
Oh am i doing something oh hi how are
you that me oh nice
well this is not what I anticipated it
being but here I stand so oh okay let's
do this new town new league nobody knows
me I can be whoever I want to who will
it be why the oh oh oh oh I get to pick
my titles oh my god oh well I've gotta
be doctor
oh I'm dr. mystery oh hell yeah oh my
god doctor unstoppable dr. funky regular
avenging oh I gotta go dr. mystery here
dr. mystery mega dr. mystery death dr.
mystery average dr. mystery average man
master hahahahaha like our dad put chest
hair on me and also shoulder hair not
too sure about that oh is that a sad
face written right into my chest oh boy
man I'm gonna go as dad I'm dr. mystery
average dad is this look going to find
me the perfect match
whoa I don't know buddy oh I really
don't know about this I'll punch myself
in the face because I'm so confident
whoa yeah get it together dr. mystery
average dad no one's gonna love you
until you learn to love yourself oh [ __ ]
dude
oh I'm sorry okay wow this is quite a
lesson to learn [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah I guess well I guess we're onto a
speed-dating course and compound look
out everybody doctoring mystery average
dad is coming to get you with his love
and cuddles I guess I was about to do
something kick all I was okay hello good
evening everybody
I'm your host MC Manny McMahon that
that's totally 2013 markiplier going on
there I don't like that you robbed my
luck there buddy boy oh you're ready for
the ride of your life if you speed date
your way through eight fighters in your
quest for the perfect match will you
find the opponent of your dreams or
leave the ring unsatisfied I'm not going
to touch that one let's find out welcome
to wrestling with emotion hey oh oh hi
oh drop what you doing the arms are in
the house arms more like twigs oh oh
he's devastated what would you do if I
had your head between mother and break
some legs to see some eggs unpossible no
legs can hold my head find something
good to fight whoa whoa I got a goose
[ __ ] something good to bite I guess oh
oh you like it dirty huh no absolutely
draw there's God there's been a grave
misunderstanding here what's your dream
match if you could see me in anything
what would it be what do you look for in
an opponent hey what do you see me
wearing huh and don't say you ha ha ha
pink spandex leotard all the way baby
okay times up you're a mystery I hate to
alarms arms love is in here later Oh
see you never arms alright bye [ __ ] you
and your boob ha ha ha ha
oh boy I'm gonna call that trite very
trite and and also he was quite pretty I
would imagine but also what the [ __ ]
alright good a bad one hello oh hi
fredom I'm mr. piggy oh oh oh evening
officer I'm looking for a real bad boy
what's your sense my body's a mess until
their hearts baked I don't use steroids
and I still moves from other wrestlers
if at it anyway relates to my YouTube
life then that's exactly the adequate
one that's taking it too far
you make me sick uh what's your dream
match prison cell five pillows okay move
along okay
put me away officer okay all right fine
all right
oh can I just all I can't right okay
well I seem to have started drawing a
dick I did not even intend to make that
a dick but uh good you there we go all
right okay all right then hi
bow down King pretty guy stands before
you I'm honored Oh
bring out the bugles blast it for King
pretty guy I'm honored only the finest
you men may lay with me why should I
pick you
whoa whoa whoa I'm a noble knight let me
challenge you I'm a filthy peasant
let me defile you I don't care puck off
your majesty you know what there's
anything to describe me it's a filthy
peasants I'm gonna go that one you you
Adam
Oh be an animal I shan't dare what do
you look for in an opponent
through prince who can match my muscle
all right then whoo-hoo farewell see
till next time pretty good bye okay
handsome indeed nice eyes funny
pretty awesome what the [ __ ]
okay that's pretty good hello how are
you woo hi
hold on your moon bag radical raise you
to rock you kill me now please just kill
me kill me now if you bag the bodacious
babe like moi what would you do with my
pod Oh Bronco bust your the night away
in the most gnarly way driver till you
can't breathe finish you off with the
Jeff I'm gonna about default good
old-fashioned wrestling moves here I
don't feel like we need to do anything
fancy my evening is filled with
boringness i watch documentaries for a
living it's great
okay gag me with a spoon that's totally
bogus now I'm a not into your fetishes
man I won't I don't want to gag you with
anything let alone the spoon you can see
me I think what would it be you need to
get with it if you catch my drift with a
shade that I don't know shade over there
it's a start corner that you can stand
in with the bag over your head that'd be
nice
you can just never look at me again and
bring your ugly ass away from this place
rats dad you still mix stupid okay
later rad inator see you rad huh smells
good smells good and that guy's probably
kid friendly just like that market ball
oh [ __ ] it oh boy death hi you're dead
Oh hola today you face death and his
name is Senor murder kill me now but in
a good way kill me come on well swear to
momento mas estancia not onl a ring okay
homeboy que luchar por lo que por venir
today we have a mass I have no idea what
that means but I'm gonna go with that
one take me now ah vocation your death
Senor muerte or whatever your name was
what's your dream match
I don't do dreams you idiota only
I don't think mr. mystery average dad is
too much into this radical death way of
living
adios All Right see ya this has been
been pretty unpleasant ah I'm not gonna
lie about they say I feel like we didn't
connect on any level Perry
nice eyes I guess that's all I could see
so good hey handsome are you man enough
to bear the bear bear
I deserve a rule I don't know I don't
know about that I don't care bear good
plush gonna brush up see if I gave you a
belly-to-belly suplex what would you do
take it like a man then come back with a
strong camel clutch
cry cry cry yeah I brought cry I just
cry I look for in an opponent a big mom
the bigger the better
blowing big fingers all day long ready
to the better the better okay alright
then oh you're varible till next time
iPad Oh Shi hoo ha hee clammy I'm gonna
I'm gonna go triple check on the clams
oh boy
oh hi ru guard oh hey buddy ready to get
funky with two dweeb Oh hee ha I am
dancing to this groovy music I like a
lot I feel really hit now that I'm
pissing really lightly I think that's a
good description of this dance yes I'm a
gangster so they say holy hula hoop II
do pretty sure whole lot hoopy-loopy do
is probably the least badass thing I
could have possibly said but okay
salutations sir are you doing we're on
the periodic table
I'm oxygen what element are you uh
hydrogen we could get together and make
things wet table fest oh my god hydrogen
ha ha oh my soul oh your fedora oh okay
what's your dream match dreams are put
an illusion
okay thank you I mean you're not wrong
but also [ __ ] you farewell
Layton - even ater all right see ya oh
good biceps I suppose see uh sure
alright let's go wait I'm saying yes to
everybody I just really tie what are you
Shrek Ricky Rob pretty sure um
piledriver oh pretty sure there's Shrek
after he fell into a swamp too deep into
the swamp this is the bottom layer of
the onion
oh boy you can see me anything that
Abood okay you are not father I mean
maybe you make all my dreams come - uh
you got a face on your arm that
kid-friendly smell good dad I know big
gnaw on Alan well you feed all of the
dreaming options now it's time to choose
your favorites it's a tough choice but
remember you can only two three oh boy
I'm not sure this was a good choice all
across the barn here really what I
wanted well radical raise out senior
murder rubbed me the wrong way I am all
aboard the bear bear
I guess the dweeb you know just to give
myself a little bit of chance and it's
between arms and King pretty guy yeah oh
my god King pretty gang yeah that's good
I'm the king of a few things oh boy the
[ __ ] was that now about what I wanted
Hodel why am now
hi oh okay ah what the [ __ ] is happening
Oh God nice nips haha hey why are you
doing this this must be a name Oh Oh God
[Music]
[ __ ] hell the [ __ ] hell happened
here oh my god okay oh boy right in code
and feel cool thanks Richard I guess
that's it then we're all done with this
one
Thank You team laser beam I need some
bleach for my eyeballs now but you know
I feel like I'm a better person for
experiencing that except in all the ways
that I'm not so that's nothing I'll take
home to my grave yeah alright then
anyway dr. mystery average dad found
love love in Qing pretty guy who I'm
pretty sure was supposed to be an
analogy of me or maybe not uh Who am I
to judge who are you to judge who's
anyone to judge maybe you're gonna have
a better chance at this finding love for
your the rest of your dreams I don't
know you can play the game for yourself
it was a long heö name your own pricing
you play for free if you want to but uh
they did pretty good I liked it good on
you team laser beam even though I'm
gonna go home and cry myself to sleep
tonight that's okay I'll just wrestle
with my emotions as I wrestle with my
pillow so thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this one
let me know what you thought down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video look
[Music]